[Music]
Hello,I am
Choi Ji-won, the director who is developing the damage. This is a
soul-like
action RPG that depicts the story of Pinocchio in various ways in an
adult overtime setting. In order to leave a strong first impression on users, I
think it should be able to bring great curiosity from the story.
In the meantime, I came up with the idea of
imagining a story that is well-known to everyone in a completely different way,
so I chose Pinocchio's adventure, which
unfolds with various attractive characters and events.  The
story of Pinocchio was
reorganized into a fictional city called Krata and a castle country with the theme of fossil disease, and the
characters that appeared in the original were also expressed in a completely different
way. For example,
Antonio, who was Geppetto's friend, was adapted into a middle-aged
woman.  So, the black rabbit who
appears as a character called Antonia and holds a liver that
appeared to correct Pinoki's habit also
appears as a group of scary assassins.
First of all, it is combat, and then the feeling of hitting,
and the level design story that everyone cares about,
and above all,  These are the keywords that were considered
very important when developing important optimization damage.
The genre was
Maniac and genre, but now it
has become one of the popular genres. Also,
since gameability is a very important genre, I
wanted to compete entirely with gameability, and I wanted to
challenge myself on the world stage.  Not only that, but
I am also a
big fan of the Soullike series as a game, and I love it so much that I stay up all
night every time a new game comes out, so I
feel that it is very exciting and fun to take on the challenge of developing this genre.
In fact, the Soullike genre is the user's
experience.  It is a genre that is very important and the game is
decided by judgment.
So we
created it with an emphasis on very realistic and familiar action, and we
put a lot of effort into the level design and background.
Existing Soul Life users will probably have a lot of
fun playing it.  I think it can be done.
And
even for users who are not comfortable with the Solilike genre,
there are a variety of options within Damage Zone, so if you
make a choice that suits your play style, you
will be able to fully feel the difficulty ease as you experience growth.
Additionally, there are many beautiful backgrounds.
If you are looking forward to the unfolding stages, you will be
able to feel great visual satisfaction.
[Music]
I think you will be able to experience a variety of battles and growth systems that you may not have experienced in other games. Also, you can enjoy the
romantic atmosphere of the era called Benefok.  Considering that we have
reinterpreted and expressed it in our own new style, I
hope you can look forward to various adventures that retell the story of the bloody lie in the original Pinocchio's Adventure.
Hello, I am the owner
of the concept and overall art at Roundway Studio Eropc.  My name
is Noh Chang-gyu, and I am impressed by the direction. Nice to meet you.
[Music] The
art team is
made up of people who love games, including me. The
organization consists of the concept part, the character background,
3D art production part, the rock developer part, the
UX part, and the
animation effects part.  The
accounting industry is comprised of
very diverse and interesting people, ranging from newcomers to those with 20 years of experience, working together. The
character Antonia is one of the very important NPCs in the victim's living room.
In the original Pinocchio, there is a character called Antonio, and
this was reinterpreted in the style of Victim's Lie.
From character concept to modeling, the
concept team, character team, animation team, and
look team
created it with great care and attention.
And it
is a character called Marionette. It
is one of the helper dolls that was initially delayed as a
doll. It became a bit ugly due to the doll incident, but there are
various reasons.  It's cute when you see it in the game, but it
's a doll in the Krat Hotel in the game. I
think
it's a character that sympathizes with the main character.
[Music] There's
almost no part in the character design that we didn't pay attention to. The
player character and
In the case of the NPC,
we paid a lot of attention to the warranty. Even the shape of the tie and
each button were
designed based on the 19th century design as much as possible.
And the most important thing while playing the main character Pad was the
pure beauty of having to learn to lie.  I
wanted to express it, but
since it is a Soullike game, the
main character
is ultimately thought of as a boss monster. I can only say that the boss monster design was
really put into the development room.
My
father-in-law is from
Colombia, and when I pass by Zepeto, I
think of him.  There
is an anecdote about Ji-an.
In addition, Polent has an NPC caterer, which I
showed you earlier. A
member of our business team
made it as an actual model. It was very fun.
And the difficult part during the production process was that in the
end,
each person had their own charisma in Solar's game.  I put
a lot of effort into it.
In the end, it was the most
fun rather than difficult, and I remember the things that Lee Min-gyu was involved in. There were almost
no monsters whose designs were completed in one go, and we redesigned them several
times.
And the
entire concepting, character, and planning teams worked together.  We came up with an
idea together,
discussed it, and came
up with a result. I remember working on it because the
results came out really well.
When the material called Vinocu was brought in,
I
had a hunch that it needed to be torn down to some extent so that the elements could be felt.  I designed the enemy concept and key art
at the time. I thought that
doing so would create a more interesting picture.
I
didn't plant a leader. I think we proceeded in that way in the hope that
our game would be seen like a light shining in the dark,
and it
was called steampunk style.  You say this a lot, but we are
looking at it internally. In fact, the
Steam period is not the base, and
logically, I
think the proposal was focused on the idea of ​​how an android would have been created if it had been created in the 19th century.
[Music] As you know,
the most  It was a rich and beautiful
era. Looking at the materials from that time, there is
quite a
lot of volume, abundance, and leisure, and there are many aesthetics left in those designs. So it
seems like it is an era that is still used a lot, and it
seems to have been very challenging. The
most beautiful was
n't always beauty.  It was a
social calling card, and
there was also something like the Road Eyeton movement.
I thought it was a time when debut gave a very big feeling. So I
wanted to include this debut in this story, and
although it was the most beautiful, in a way, let's express it in the
darkest
style.  I
was thinking about it, and I think that
would be the best fit for the game, so I made this choice.
In fact, Blood Lies
is not the only place where doll monsters appear. Although they
were already revealed in the video, there are
also many monsters that have changed due to some reason.  The reason why the
monsters are set as dolls
is that in the city of Klat, which has developed greatly thanks to dolls, the dolls were triggered to attack humans for some reason. And
finding out those reasons can be seen as one of the contents of this game.
[Music]
First of all, the visuals.  For this purpose, we are
using the best engine.
Since it is 7, TA and the art director are
applying as much of the latest technology as possible. We are
also applying fsr and dlss.
For performance, we are utilizing the technologies we are using
to the limit.  We are
pursuing one thing. We are
putting a lot of effort into it. We are
developing the acting and characters using Marvelous Designer for initial expression, and we have
newly created all SS textures based on PBR.
[Music]
The most important thing is the development of the game.  Because we
believe it is about delivering pure fun, we did not develop a
difficulty adjustment function because we wanted to minimize the variable.
However, as
mentioned earlier, users
have a variety of options, so they can
choose the appropriate one according to their play style and
grow through the process.  I
think you can feel the difficulty.
[Music]
There are various new combat systems introduced in Damage False. The first thing I
can tell you about is the weapon combination system. When you
separate the handles of the weapons and
combine them with different types, you get a
completely different experience.  It becomes a weapon with performance and characteristics,
and since the main character P is
made with a doll body, you
can enjoy a more dynamic battle by replacing or strengthening the prosthetic arm called the left arm Legion,
as well as
through a system called blood organ.  You
can acquire various growth skills, and you can
configure a growth tree that suits each user and specialize in a combat style that suits you.
In the damage lies,
there are not only dolls, but also various races. There are combat characteristics suitable for each race, and there are combat characteristics suited to each race.  It is very
important to formulate an advantageous battle strategy to deal with the enemy. And because
powerful bosses appear in each chapter, it is
very important to fully understand and study the boss' species, characteristics, and various combat systems. You can
feel the best hitting in False Damage.  We
've put more focus and effort than ever before so that you
can experience the high-quality sound and visuals for yourself.
[Music]
As this is our first Soullike game, we are doing our
best to produce the
best combat for our users.  We will do our best to
provide you with the best experience possible.
Currently, the entire development team, including me, is
working hard until the end to provide you with the best experience. Please look
forward to it and thank you for the last time.